>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
Good afternoon everyone.
It is a big pleasure
for me to welcome you
to this special program today.
My name is Martha Kennedy.
I am a Curator of Popular
Graphic Art in the Prints
and Photographs Division.
And we are very pleased to have two
outstanding and funny cartoonists
with us today to share
their perspectives
on political cartooning.
This panel is cosponsored by the
Prints and Photographs Division,
the Swann Foundation for
Caricature and Cartoon,
and the Interpretive
Programs Office.
This event is part of
public programming connected
with a very fine special exhibition
entitled "Pointing Their Pens,
Herblock and Fellow
Cartoonists Confront the Issues."
And this is curated by my
colleague, Sara Duke, who I think is
in the audience here [laughter].
Another preliminary comment.
We do plan time for
questions at the end
of the cartoonists' presentations
and I hope you have some questions.
This program is being
filmed for webcast
and that's why we have all these
blinding lights up right now.
So please understand that
if you ask a question,
you are giving permission
to be filmed.
Signe Wilkinson and Ann Telnaes
have to the Library at a time
when public attention and
debate over the significance
of the Charlie Hebdo
tragedy and the role
of free speech have
been reinvigorated.
Causes, you might ask.
"Doonesbury's" creator,
Gary Trudeau,
recently commented
critically on the nature
of the Charlie Hebdo
cartoonist's work,
describing it as "punching down."
Many of his peers disagreed,
including our cartoonists
here today.
Also, when the PEN/Faulkner
Writers' Group recently decided
to make an award to
Charlie Hebdo Magazine ,
five member writers
publicly declined
to attend the group's
fundraising gala.
So, against this unanticipated
backdrop,
we asked these two distinguished
cartoonists to share their responses
to the tragic murders
of the five cartoonists
at Charlie Hebdo Magazine in
January of this year, their thoughts
on free speech, other
cartoonists' related work,
and their takes on
Trudeau's comments.
In addition to these very timely
concerns, we also asked them to show
and discuss their own controversial
cartoons and cartoons relating
to women's issues and gender issues.
Signe and Ann are among a
very small number of women
who pursue political cartooning
as their main professional focus.
Okay. I'm going to --
-- Signe Wilkinson is
the Editorial Cartoonist
for the Philadelphia Daily News --
>> Signe Wilkinson: I'm on the left.
[ Laughter ]
>> Martha H. Kennedy: --
and she is also contributing
to the Philadelphia
Enquirer these days.
In 1992 she became the first
woman to win the Pulitzer Prize
for her political cartoons.
And this prize-winning group focused
on human needs and
social conditions.
She has received many other
prestigious awards including the
Thomas Nast Award from the
Overseas Press Club in 1996, 2000,
2006, and this year, too.
She's also received the Robert F.
Kennedy Journalism Award in 2002
and 2008, and the Visionary
Woman Award
from Philadelphia's Moore
College of Art and Design in 2011.
She served as President
of the Association
of American Editorial
Cartoonists in 1994/'95.
She's published two collections
of her wonderfully hard-hitting
eye-catching cartoons,
and they included One Nation
Under Surveillance in 2005,
and Abortion Cartoons
on Demand in 1992.
She's also drawn cartoons
for Ms. Magazine,
Organic Gardening ,
and other publications.
Her work has been exhibited
widely in group and solo shows.
She launched "The Family
Tree," which is a comic strip
that was syndicated and distributed
by United Media in 2007
and ended it in 2011.
Ann Telnaes, on the right,
creates animated editorial cartoons
and a blog of print cartoons.
Ann made gifs and sketches
for the Washington Post .
In 2001 she became the second
woman to win the Pulitzer Prize
for her political cartoons,
and they focused
on the presidential
election of 2000.
Other notable awards she has
received are the Clifford K.
and James T. Berryman Award from
the National Press Foundation
in 2003 and 2006.
And in 2011 she was a finalist
for the Herblock Prize
in Editorial Cartooning.
In 1997 she also won a National
Headliners Award and other awards.
She has served as the Vice
President of the Association
of American Editorial
Cartoonists and is a member
of the Cartoonists Rights
Network International.
Her cartoons have been exhibited
nationally and internationally,
including a solo exhibit
here at the Library in 2004.
She has published two
collections of her bold,
streamlined cartoon drawings
in Humor's Edge which was a
companion volume to her exhibition,
and Dick in 2006 which
revolved around cartoons
of then Vice President Dick Cheney.
Beginning in 2002 Ann contributed
to the daily comic "Six Chicks"
for several years and to the online
publication Women's eNews from
2002 to 2009.
Much more could be said about both
of these wonderful cartoonists,
but I would like to ask you to
welcome them to our program today.
[ Applause ]
All right, just -- I'm
going to ask Signe to begin
by sharing her reactions to
the Charlie Hebdo tragedy,
and how she framed her thought
process in responded to it, first.
Thank you.
>> Signe Wilkinson:
Thank you, Martha.
When we got started on
this, planning this event,
it was long before Charlie Hebdo .
It was long before the more recent
controversies, and we were sort
of wondering what the focus
would be, just free speech."
And I regret to say that tragedy
has really become the centerpiece
of what most cartoonists are
talking and arguing about right now.
And just to be clear, my position is
that cartoonists don't kill people.
Cartoons can't kill people.
Humorless, religious fanatics
generally do, or more often they do.
A cartoon, a little
cartoon, a drawing on paper,
pixels on a screen, cannot
stone anyone to death,
it cannot sever a head, it
cannot send anyone to jail.
And so the proportionality of what
we're talking about, a cartoon,
the drawing of a cartoon, and the
results that happened on January 7th
in Paris are just so
disproportionate
that it's almost hard to even
talk about it as well, you know,
one thing equals the other.
But my interest in this goes back
to the Danish cartoons which started
in 2005, and erupted in 2006
after several months of ginning
up controversy about them.
And I learned then that it's
really not about the image
of Mohammad being prohibited
from being -- from drawing.
And that's what I'd like to talk
about today, is the use of symbols
and how we come to
focus on one thing.
But, in reality, for at
least me as a cartoonist,
it's been quite different.
This, of course, this is
grabbed off the Internet,
so I'm sorry the resolution
isn't good enough for you
to be really shocked and
appalled that I am showing them.
And this is a collection of the
Danish cartoons with the most,
the one that caused
the most controversy
up on the top with the turban.
When that happened, it took a
while for the controversy to bubble
over from Europe to
the United States.
And nobody really knew that --
what it was all about, that this --
that drawing Mohammad
was even a problem.
One of the first papers
to publish the image
in the United States was the
Austin Statesman American ,
which did it too early.
No one knew that it was -- that
this was a prohibited image,
and they got no reaction.
People didn't know they were
supposed to be afraid and appalled.
But shortly thereafter, it really
hit the fan and there were only
about five other papers in the
country that managed to put
in a news item in the paper.
And one of them was the
Philadelphia Enquirer .
I word at the Daily News at
the time, and our paper did not.
The Enquirer put one in one of
the interior pages in a little box
with an explanation and --
just to alert its readers,
this is what we're talking about.
There were protests.
There were many follow-ups, meetings
with people who were unhappy.
But what it did was
start a conversation
in the city of Philadelphia.
And right now we have a very
strong interfaith movement that,
because it brought people
together to actually talk
about these things
across religious lines.
My editor, when I said, ooh,
I want to draw Mohammad, said,
mm, not so sure about that.
And he backed me up on many,
many other controversies.
So I stewed for a couple of days
to figure out how I could do it.
And I did this cartoon
-- "The Big Fat Book
of Offensive Religious Cartoons."
[ Laughter ]
That's Mohammad, third
from the right [laughter].
This cartoon has been reprinted
widely and was just sent
around the world again via Twitter
after Charlie Hebdo
, with no controversy.
And the reason is that
Mohammad is cheerful,
happy, and one of the guys.
He's not portrayed negatively.
And this is the point
I want to make.
That it isn't about
drawing Mohammad.
It's how Mohammad is drawn.
And so it's a political, it's
the politics; it's not the image.
And I have had this experience
in other cartoons as well.
Oh, oops [laughter].
Wait, this isn't a
gay wedding, is it?
[ Laughter ]
Well, about half my audience like
this cartoon a lot [laughter].
About half my audience said,
"One should not be putting
a prophet in the newspaper."
And then my Jewish readers said,
"How dare you put leavened bread.
[ Laughter ]
"That was a sedar dinner."
I can't please everyone
all the time.
I said, "That was my
artistic license.
Have you ever tried to
draw matzo [laughter]?"
So, again -- but I've
done cartoons --
I did one with the Pope's
coming to Philadelphia.
I want you all not to be there.
There's no room in
Philadelphia next September.
But the Archbishop liked it so
much, he sent it to the Vatican.
It's like, okay, you can't do it
sometimes, you can do it others.
And this -- we're covering the
major religions I've pissed off
over my career.
This was a tiny little illustration
in 1992 that went with a letter
about Arab attacks on Israelis.
It appeared on our Letters Page.
Next day it was in birdcages.
No one commented on it.
About three months
later, this was 1992,
a woman named Lynn
Yeakel was running
against Arlen Specter,
our incumbent Senator.
And she was gaining on him.
It was the Year of the Woman,
Clinton was running, and Spector all
of a sudden's camp
got a little nervous.
So they started a whispering
campaign about her,
saying that she was anti-Semitic
for the most minor
infraction you can imagine.
It was -- it didn't even involve
her, but somebody at her church,
a thousand-member church.
So there were letters to
the editor about that.
And just by happenstance I drew
this with Lynn Yeakel being asked
to prove that she is
not anti-Semitic.
I was eviscerated for
this tiny little cartoon.
People called, they wrote, people
came into the office and suggested
to my editors that I find
other employment, that I was --
called in letters "feminism's
own Goebbels," et cetera.
There was a little blowback.
Let's just put it that
way [laughter].
But the argument was I should not
use the Star of David in a cartoon.
However, this was okay.
This was not.
And it goes back to my points
on the other prophets
that we have looked at.
It's not the symbol, it's
not the prophet itself.
It's the politics behind it.
And every group holds
certain things sacred.
The question in front of us is
whether we can let each group decide
for everyone else what is sacred.
And if we do, we will
not be drawing cartoons.
So that's -- I turn
it over now to Ann
to continue our --
do I have one more?
>> Yes.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Oh, yes.
Just a small historical [laughter]
-- It was an early style [laughter].
It was my 1876 style.
I used to call it -- I used to sign
them "Joseph Keppler [laughter]."
If you take a look at this,
this was a double-truck
in Harper's Weekly called
"The Religious Vanity Fair."
If you start from the left,
that is a stereotypical,
horrible Jewish person.
The little, next one to the right
is the humbug Presbyterians.
Way over on the right, it's the
Catholic selling indulgences.
The guy with his hand up is
the Baptist offering baptism.
You get over to polygamy.
You have the Episcopalians
selling ritual salvation.
And the guy on the couch was the
New Age minister of the time,
Henry Ward Beecher,
who was promising the
"love road to heaven [laughter]."
This is our heritage.
It's irreverent and it treats all --
it treats all religions with
a good dose of skepticism.
My point is that in --
and my feeling is that as new
religions come this is the
marketplace that they're entering.
And if we treat all of
them equally they will show
up in a cartoon like this, too.
[ Applause ]
>> Ann Telnaes: Is it
this one to look for?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Yes.
>> Ann Telnaes: Okay.
Okay. I have to apologize.
I, of course, came down with a
cold first thing this morning.
So my voice is like a
couple of steps down.
So I apologize for that.
So Signe talked about symbols.
I'm going to talk about the
red line that everybody seems
to be discussing, especially
now with --
after Charlie Hebdo
and Gary Trudeau.
Of course, as Signe mentioned,
this really did start in 2006
with the Danish cartoon controversy.
This was a cartoon that I drew at
the time in response to all our --
the debate that was going on within
the cartooning community here
in the United States.
People were very divided then.
I would say at that point really a
lot of people thought that the --
what the Danish cartoonist
did was not appropriate.
And I was frankly surprised
at a lot of my colleagues,
a lot of my liberal
colleagues, that they really felt
that they had definitely
crossed over a line.
But my point here was that
everybody has their own red line.
Everybody has a different opinion
about what insults them,
what makes them angry.
So if you start doing red
lines, I wanted to show
that eventually you
box in the cartoonist,
the writer, the whatever.
And that's the reason
I created that one.
Another thing that came out of the
Danish cartoon controversy was just
the different type of censors
that we had around the world.
You know, of course you probably
know that in Europe they have a lot
of laws against the fact
that -- a Holocaust denier,
that you actually think
the Holocaust didn't exist.
You're not allowed to say that.
They throw people in jail for that.
I think those people are nuts.
I think they're crazy.
They -- you know, they obviously
don't know their history.
But I don't think they
should be thrown in jail
because all you're doing is you're
just -- you know, ridicule them.
Tell them they're stupid.
Draw cartoons about them.
But to make it against the law
to say something idiotic,
I think, is idiotic.
So, and this is kind
of the way I feel
about the whole thing [laughter].
"I'm all for free speech unless
I find it personally offensive."
So now, getting around
to Charlie Hebdo .
That was a really difficult time.
I think that really
changed the conversation,
at least in the cartooning
community.
And I really felt that that was sort
of going to be the catalyst for us.
I really thought that that was
going to change even the cartoonists
that had felt that the
Danish cartoon controversy,
the Danish cartoons were wrong
and they shouldn't have done it.
I thought that, you know, killing
five cartoonists in cold blood
over what they drew would be
enough for people to say "Enough,
that's ridiculous," you know?
If we're going to be a civil
society, that we're going
to kill people over what they
say and draw is just absurd.
So I was not working
for the Washington Post during
the Danish cartoon controversy.
But I was during Charlie Hebdo .
I started in 2008.
So this was my immediate
response to the killings.
I was shocked.
You know, it's kind of hard
to do a hard-hitting
cartoon when you're shocked.
But this was after
the iconic photograph
of the Charlie Hebdo editor.
That he had on that same shirt and
he was holding up his fist after,
I think, the bombings
is what it was,
the bombings of the
Charlie Hebdo offices.
I'm just showing you how
this appeared online.
I'm going to show you individual
pieces so you can actually read it.
This was a cartoon essay
I did in response to --
after the Charlie Hebdo killings,
after the initial shock wore
off and people condemned it.
Then all of a sudden
we started having,
not just with the cartoonists, with
writers talking about how, you know,
what the Charlie Hebdo
cartoonists did was questionable.
It was in bad taste.
It was racist cartoons.
You know, it was anti-Semitic.
It was whatever.
So let me just go through
the panels real quick.
"So now that the shock
of the murders has turned
to questioning Charlie
Hebdo's satire" --
"Some cartoonists and writers
have described the cartoons
as anti-Muslim, blasphemous,
offensive and bigoted.
The 2009 firing of a cartoonist
who wrote an anti-Semitic
column has also been mentioned."
"First of all, I am not a
big fan of bathroom humor.
Secondly, and more seriously,
it's a valid discussion to have
about why the divisions
between people are so deep
and our political discourse
has become so toxic --
However, that is not what we
should be talking about now.
Do we condone threats of
violence toward individuals
because of what they say or draw,
regardless of how offensive
the words or images are?
No. Because what happens once we get
beyond the easy images to condemn --
"And who makes that decision?
" All people must have the right
to express themselves without fear,
otherwise we risk losing
our freedoms."
So my point is, you know, when we
talk about what are offensive images
and what should we not be drawing
or what should we not be saying,
my question back to you is,
who makes that decision?
Are we going to let
government make that decision?
Do we let individual religious
institutions make that decision?
I am all for letting the idiots say
stupid things in order for us all
to be able to say what
we want to say.
I'll put up with the dumb people
in order to keep those freedoms.
Am I done here?
Are we --
>> Martha H. Kennedy: I
don't know [inaudible].
>> Ann Telnaes: Let's
see where we're going.
Ah, it's Signe.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Just one
note on the Danish cartoons.
Just as I said, if the
Enquirer -- it started --
the publication started a dialog.
It did in Denmark, too.
And as a matter of fact, one of the
young imams who was really the one
who went out of his way to find
others to protest the cartoons has
since recanted his
point of view and said
that the paper should have
the right to publish them.
So, again, a cartoonist
is not the end of a --
a cartoon is not the end of a
conversation; it's the start of one.
But you can't have a conversation
if one of the people is shot dead.
So I'm all for not shooting
cartoonists personally,
and I'm going to say that publicly.
This is just a little round-up that
we're not alone in this discussion.
Cartooning is a worldwide
sport these days.
This is Latuff from Brazil who --
and I apologize to my colleagues
whose cartoons I'm about to show.
I did not ask for their
permission to show them at this,
although I have asked Latuff
in the past if I might.
He's shooting to Charlie Hebdo
and hitting the mosque in the back.
But the reason we need
to pay attention to --
and this is the first day out.
And there were tons
of cartoons like this
from cartoonists all over the world.
But international cartoonists
have other concerns as well.
This is another one by
Latuff drawing about Muslims.
It's freedom of speech.
Drawing about Jews.
It's anti-Semitism.
And there's a big feeling among
cartoonists around the world, not --
I mean not universally but in
many countries, that we do --
we are unequal in the
way we treat things.
But we should know that.
I mean, we might not agree with it.
We might think we're equal.
But we should know how
others perceive us.
This is an Indian woman cartoonist,
and she's gotten in trouble
because she's talked about
religious people in India and rape.
"So why don't you tell your guru
to stop molesting the girls?
'Til then, cartoons on
him will be continued."
And that's a pretty
brave cartoon for someone
in India, especially a woman.
It's not generally
encouraged apparently.
She's had a lot of blowback.
And lastly, this is the wonderful
cartoonist, Ali Farzat, from Syria,
who was a very courageous
anti-government cartoonist.
And in 2011 someone, we
don't know exactly who,
I guess could be guessed, abducted
him, several masked people,
beat him, as you can
see, and then stomped
on his hands until they were broken.
This is what cartoonists
around the world --
but not always face
the same thing --
but there's real, real
persecution against them and --
but this is Ali Farzat's reply.
[ Laughter ]
It's the spirit of
cartoonists everywhere
and that's what we're
tapping into here.
>> Thank you.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: At this point
I'm going to ask Ann to show some
of her most controversial cartoons.
And if we have time
later we will try
to access an additional
controversial cartoon
by Signe if we can do that.
But Signe's already covered some
really controversial cartoons
in her earlier remarks.
Okay?
>> Ann Telnaes: Okay.
So when -- I'm going to
show you two of them.
The last one we're going
to try to show at the end.
Unfortunately, it's an
animation, so technology.
We couldn't get it to work properly
and we're scared we couldn't
come back to the slideshow.
So I will tell it to you.
But I was really pleased
with myself.
I didn't do this on purpose.
But I actually have covered
all three major religions
to insult [laughter].
Okay. So the reason I'm
showing you three of these --
I'm not exactly sure which
one actually resulted
in me getting threats, real threats.
What happened was it was
a Islamic group based
in the U.K. This is what
I figured out later on.
Islamic group based in the U.K.
who went to my website and went
into my archives and picked
these cartoons and put them
on Iranian magazine website.
And then I started getting these
e-mails that all sounded alike
about what an awful person I was
for doing these, which was fine.
I don't care about that.
We all get threats.
It's no big deal.
But then I got a couple of like I'm
going to kill you threats from --
they traced them back to
Saudi, Arabia, and Kuwait.
My first experience with the FBI.
That was fun.
So anyway.
That was right after 911.
This is before the Danish cartoon
controversy and Charlie Hebdo .
Ah, this was fun [laughter].
As you all might remember,
the Catholic Church sex abuse
scandal here in the States.
I did many cartoons about that.
Got lots of reactions from people
about how I was Catholic-bashing.
And this one was particularly
an interesting one.
The Minneapolis paper
published it, so then --
I will part of it if
I can actually see it.
Let' see. The Chancellor of
the Archdiocese of Saint Paul,
Minneapolis wrote a letter.
He didn't try to kill me, but he
did write a letter to the editor.
And we wrote, "To use the Vatican's
recent same-sex marriage document
to portray the Vatican
as lecherously winking
at a legal same-sex unions
and pedophilia is a vicious
and unfair slur against our church,
its religions, and
its lay faithful."
And my point about
that is, you know,
I don't do cartoons blasting people
for their individual
religious beliefs.
That's your deal.
But if a leader of a
church, if the leadership
of a church inserts itself
in the political process,
which the Catholic Church does
with their reproductive rights
stances, they are fair game.
So that is why I do these cartoons.
And the last one we
can't show you right now,
but suffice to say,
it's about Netanyahu.
So maybe we'll see that later on.
I don't know what's
next [inaudible].
>> Signe Wilkinson: Okay.
Do you want to say anything about --
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Okay.
No. Just briefly -- the
next section is on --
>> Signe Wilkinson: Chick humor.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Right.
[ Laughter ]
We've had [inaudible] about women,
their position, and
other gender issues.
>> Ann Telnaes: And how we kind of,
being female editorial cartoonists,
how we might take a little
bit different take on things.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Okay.
So I'm not going to --
these aren't cartoons
about politics and women's issues.
I've done a ton on them.
But there are really, I
think, a few different --
there are certain cartoons
that I've done
that I don't think a
man would have done.
And this is one of them.
This is about me shopping
with my daughter
in the Brittany Spears
era [laughter].
Okay. It's four parts.
I'm not happy [laughter],
but I get an idea.
[ Laughter ]
It's again -- I mean I've been
accused of being anti-Muslim, but,
you know, you can use imagery
in many different ways.
And I appreciate the hijab for
being there for me as a parent.
The next one, "If God
had wanted women
to have octuplets --
I don't think so."
Anyone who's actually birthed a baby
would understand how difficult two
would be as opposed to eight.
That was, remember, when
the Octomom was big.
And I will -- I actually
think when people say,
okay, how do you draw women?
One thing a woman -- a woman does
not have trouble drawing other
women's breasts.
They're not sex objects.
They're just part of an anatomy.
And I think if you look at
various cartoons about women,
I think sometimes, not always,
there's a tendency to have trouble
with that part of the anatomy.
So a woman -- oh, a woman
is a little freer I think,
or at least knows what
she's talking about.
This was actually --
this is about abortion.
This is quite some time ago.
She sees the results positive.
She starts thinking and thinking,
and it's dawn, and it's dusk,
and it's thinking and it's thinking.
She goes to the abortion clinic
and come back in 24 hours
after you've thought it over.
And the reason I did this
was that I had had a baby,
and I know the second that you
think that you might be pregnant,
that's the only thing
that you think about.
And so, for a guy across the street
at the Supreme Court to tell me
that I need 24 more hours to
think about it is, just to me,
so insulting and has no
understanding of what it's
like to actually be pregnant,
whether you want the baby or not.
And lastly I'll go back -- I'll
say, you know, there is always,
it's always talked about medical
stuff having to do with women.
And men, too.
But men don't have to read reports
on whether a mammogram
is a good idea or not.
"If women were meant
to have mammograms."
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
[ Inaudible Conversations ]
What? You --
>> Just [inaudible].
>> Signe Wilkinson: And you
want to do yours from the --
>> Ann Telnaes: I'll just talk.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Oh, okay.
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah.
Okay. So, continuing that theme.
This is actually something I did in
[inaudible] or the Hillary Campaign
when she got so much criticism about
how she wasn't sensitive enough
or feeling enough or caring enough
or connecting with her voters.
And, of course, this has
come up again just recently.
And I thought, well,
that's really interesting.
They want her to be
tough but they want her
to cry, too, at the same time.
So I started thinking about
during the Salem Witch Trials,
what did they do to find
out if you were a witch.
They threw you in the water and if
you floated you were a witch and,
therefore, they're going to know.
But [inaudible].
So, but if, if you actually
drowned then you're innocent,
but you're screwed [laughter],
so I thought that's kind
of apropos to Hillary.
Next. I love these cartoons
because I don't have to
draw them [laughter].
So this is, of course,
the famous painting
about the writing of
the Constitution.
"Let's agree, we don't give
women the right to vote."
A good example of why
diversity's [inaudible].
Oh, man. This is a -- I think it's
getting a little bit better now.
I did this in the early 2000s
but, "Study shows 8% of women
in movies are over the age of 35."
You know, no problem
getting a 65-year-old guy
with a 25-year-old
woman on the screen.
Oh, no.
>> Thanks.
>> Ann Telnaes: Thanks.
And I just wanted to show
you this in terms of --
we need to be a little bit more
serious about why it's important
to have women editorial cartoonists.
Because we're women we do notice
things important to women.
And when I first started
out in editorial cartooning I was
reading The Christian Science
Monitor a great deal.
And they had some really
great stories
about the plight of
Afghanistan women.
And that's the first time I had
ever heard about the Taliban.
That was the first cartoon I ever
did that was [inaudible] in 1996,
which came back to
haunt us [inaudible].
>> Oh, no, this.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Ann Telnaes: If you're
in D.C., you might remember
that this is actually a
photograph on the front page
of the Washington Post where they
showed George W. Bush signing one
of those umpteenth partial
birth abortion signs.
And, of course, every single
lawmaker behind him was
in a suit, a man's suit.
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
That's a real power suit.
>> Ann Telnaes: That is, yeah.
Oh, and that's -- yeah, okay.
This is my response to
gay marriage [inaudible].
Most of male colleagues, you know,
would talk about gay marriage
in the sense of, you
know, is it appropriate,
is it natural, is it whatever?
And I thought, let's
talk about marriage
as an institute just to begin with.
It's not that it's been so
great for women [inaudible].
Yeah, we -- it's -- in the
beginning they kind of traded women
for things, so I thought well,
why don't we just have this woman
express to this newly-wed couple,
"So which one of you gets to endure
centuries of setting class status
and being legally considered
the property of your husband?"
>> None.
>> Ann Telnaes: I think that's it.
Nope, we got one more,
okay [laughter].
I guess this is in the
[inaudible] things used somewhere.
I don't know [laughter].
But it's fun.
>> Signe Wilkinson: And
I think that is it, yes.
>> Ann Telnaes: So, did you --
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
That's the -- yeah.
That the end of the planned
part of the presentation.
I'd like to open up for questions
to the two cartoonists right now.
So [inaudible].
>> Ann Telnaes: Yes.
We'll stand.
We're short.
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
And I can also --
>> Signe Wilkinson: Yeah [laughter].
>> Martha H. Kennedy: I can
try to ask this in animation.
>> Ann Telnaes: Oh, why don't
you do that while we talk.
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
Oh, while you talk, okay?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Okay,
question number one.
>> Ann Telnaes: Come on, guys.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Way
in the back, in the hat.
>> Have you had an editor
cancel a cartoon you've done
at your [inaudible] home paper?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Well,
the one I showed early-on was
after I was not going
to do a cartoon directly
on Charlie Hebdo --
or the Danish cartoons.
But eventually I did do one.
So it -- and I think
it was a better cartoon
because I paused and
thought about it.
There was one local cartoon
that -- at the -- in my --
my cartoons appear in both the
Enquirer and the Daily News .
It appeared in the Daily News .
the Enquirer did
not want to run it.
But I still think it was --
thought it was a great cartoon.
And so -- the but the
Daily News did.
So, you know, editors, you can't
figure them out [laughter].
You just --
>> Ann Telnaes: But --
and along the same lines,
since we have the animation up,
my editor backed me up completely
on this one, Fred Hiatt
at the Washington Post .
I work at home so I
was -- this was --
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Shoot.
I was trying to get it to run.
I'm --
>> Ann Telnaes: I'll talk about
it while she's retrieving it.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Okay.
>> Ann Telnaes: Anyway, so I
had done this over the weekend
and then I just -- I upload it
and then an editor will finalize
it and take a look at it.
So, you know, I did that
Sunday thinking nothing of it.
It was about the bombings
in Gaza last year where all
of you are probably
aware that, you know,
a lot of Palestinians were killed,
a lot of children were killed.
And I thought, well, I want
to do a cartoon about this.
I don't want to put any
blood in it or anything.
I just want to do something
criticizing really both sides,
you know?
Because children are innocent.
Children don't have a say in this.
They don't have a say whether
or not they get bombed.
So I drew Netanyahu doing this.
Let's show.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: All right.
I'm trying to get it to --
>> Ann Telnaes: And I apologize
if you're going to watch an ad.
But they do this.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Right.
Sorry, what?
>> Go down --
>> Go down to the --
>> Go down.
>> Here it is.
[ Knocking Sound ]
>> Ann Telnaes: And that's
basically it [laughter].
So you can -- yeah, because it's
going to roll over to the next one.
So --
>> Save up to a thousand dollars.
>> Ann Telnaes: See.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Okay.
[ Laughter ]
All right, all right.
>> Ann Telnaes: Mattress.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Okay.
>> Ann Telnaes: So anyway.
So what ended up happening
is, you know, I sent it in.
Didn't hear anything.
And then by midweek
my direct editor, Jim,
just kind of sends
me an e-mail message.
Did you hear anything
back about that cartoon?
I'm like well, I'm starting
to get e-mails, a few of them.
You know, just regular old, you
know, you're an idiot stuff.
And then, come to find out,
Monday morning first thing,
every single Israeli Jewish special
interest group called Fred Hiatt's
office to complain
about that cartoon.
And then there's an article in the
Israeli -- what is it, The Post,
The Jerusalem Daily Post .
Yes, Jerusalem Post , condemning
-- well, talking about it and,
of course, you know,
having statements
from different organizations.
They didn't bother
asking me about it.
So I wasn't in there.
And then I started getting
another round of e-mails
that were the most -- I have never
gotten e-mails like this before.
I mean, every single cartoonist
gets, you know, mean e-mails talking
about what an idiot you are, you
shouldn't be doing cartooning,
you know, you're this, you're that.
This was the most misogynistic
disgusting e-mails that I've gotten.
I'm not saying it's from those
organizations, because it wasn't.
It was just from individuals.
But it's -- I think it's indicative
of what -- where we're going,
you know, with conversation
and social media.
I'm not the first woman
that's gotten that.
But it's -- it was a
first for me in my career.
So, I guess we can
just continue with --
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
Yeah, other questions.
>> Ann Telnaes: That hat [laughter].
>> Congratulations, Signe,
[inaudible] the Overseas
Press Club --
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> -- we've heard recently
from foreign cartoonists
who have come here and said they
wanted [inaudible] translate
across the world for
moving text [inaudible].
Are there special things
about what you do
that you think play well
overseas [inaudible],
things you do that you're
conscious of, I want this to play
across the world, or
not so much [inaudible].
>> Signe Wilkinson: Go ahead.
You're closest.
>> Ann Telnaes: My work tends to
be more image-heavy than words.
So I think that's just my
natural tendency to do, do it.
I don't -- no, I don't,
I don't necessarily
change anything that way.
I mean, I -- I think just the fact
that we have the Internet now
is just amazing development
for editorial cartoonists because
we can reach so many people.
Of course it gets us
in trouble, too.
And that's why we ended up with
the Danish cartoon conversation.
>> Signe Wilkinson: I'm a
really local cartoonist.
So my stuff depends on
people knowing what's going
on in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania
mostly and the environs.
So I don't think about how it's
going to be playing in Beijing
because I don't think
they're interested.
So, you know, some of them
have, as I said earlier, have --
on the more international
topics have gone around.
But I don't draw for an
international audience.
For the Philadelphia Daily News ,
Camden is a foreign
assignment [laughter].
How about --
>> Martha H. Kennedy:
[Inaudible], yeah.
>> Most [inaudible] of [inaudible]
but I realize there was
a [inaudible] second part
where you guys are
being [inaudible].
But, whatever.
There's a more serious side to it
when you talk to -- about politics.
And, as an artist, I'm
[inaudible] your opinions about --
because let's take for instance
there was a senator who went to,
I think it was Japan,
not too long ago.
He had [inaudible].
So do you think that the artist is
overstepping her or her boundaries
in making political gestures at
what we would call serious issues?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Baa.
Well, I'm not sure how that --
I think that was South Korea was
the ambassador who was just coming
out of a meeting and I don't --
I'm not sure how that
translates to cartooning.
But the -- you know,
that's what we do.
We take difficult cartoons and --
I mean difficult issues and
tragedies sometimes and try
to give them -- give a
connection, an emotional connection,
about how one could feel about them.
So I think cartoons are sort of
a link in a newspaper or website
between an actual event and how
people feel about that event.
And, of course, the reaction
is different whether you agree
with the cartoonist or not.
And I think where it's
going is that --
where once we were in
broad-based publications
like the Washington Post or
in my papers in Philadelphia,
now people are going into more
niche online publications,
so that if people want
to access a cartoonist,
they go to the ones they already
agree with, and are happy with them.
And then it's harder -- I
think the downside of that is
that you don't start the
conversation across party lines
or ideological or religious lines.
And I think that's not
just about cartooning
but about the media generally.
All sorts of things.
That didn't answer your question,
but Ann will answer it --
>> Ann Telnaes: No,
no way [laughter].
No, I know.
Martha can answer it.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Okay.
I'd like to ask both of you,
why there are so few women
in political cartooning.
Where does --
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I know this is -- it's
sort of a leading question,
but I think it's important,
you know,
to hear both your takes on that.
>> Signe Wilkinson: You know,
without Charlie Hebdo ,
that would have been
the first question.
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah, right.
We've had -- we've gone beyond, yes.
I don't know.
I mean, there's -- because
it started that way.
Because most editors were male
and you feel more comfortable
with someone that's like you.
I don't know.
I mean I was in animation.
We had the same -- we
had the same issue there,
that there weren't a lot
of women in the beginning.
It's changing.
I mean, it's -- the reason I make
fun of that question, on a test,
is because it's like
for us, we don't --
do we consider ourselves
as women cartoonists?
No.
>> Signe Wilkinson: No.
>> Ann Telnaes: No.
>> Signe Wilkinson: We consider
ourselves cartoonists --
>> Ann Telnaes: 'toonists.
>> Signe Wilkinson: God damn it.
>> Ann Telnaes: Damn it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
You said God damn it [laughter].
>> Signe Wilkinson: If
there was a god, damn it.
Oh, no.
>> Do you think that any of your
more controversial cartoons,
any of the ones that got more of
a reaction, would have gotten less
of a reaction if you were males?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Well, a
lot of my hate mail begins,
"Dear Mr. Wilkinson [laughter]."
Seriously.
Because my picture
isn't in the paper,
and Signe's an ambiguous name.
And you're going to
have to answer that one.
But I don't think so.
I think people are -- they
-- if they hate an image,
they hate the image whether
you're a woman or a man.
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah.
I don't -- not really.
I mean I've done cartoons that
have had the woman's point of view
where I've gotten a couple of men
like oh, you're just a man-hater,
but that's not [inaudible].
Sandy.
>> I'm interested in hearing your
reactions to Gary Trudeau's remarks
from -- like Charlie Hebdo .
What he seemed to be pointing out
was everybody should really be,
to be concerned about
what they said.
But on the other hand that some
of the Charlie Hebdo cartoons were
really stirring a racist Islamic pot
[inaudible] Islamic pot.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Go ahead.
You first.
>> Ann Telnaes: Me first?
You first?
Yeah. I actually wrote a
response to Gary Trudeau
in my Washington Post blog, which
is an interesting experience for me
because writing is not my thing.
But sometimes you just
need to write it.
I don't agree with Gary Trudeau.
You know, I respect him,
as I said in my column.
I think he's, he's really one
of the greats in our field.
I just think he chose some very
unfortunate words, you know.
To throw hate speech in there,
to, you know, to describe me
as a free-speech fundamentalist
extreme -- no, fundamentalist --
>> Martha H. Kennedy: A fanatic.
>> Ann Telnaes: -- fanatic.
That was it, fanatic.
You know, I just don't
agree with that.
Like I said, I think that, you
know, it's important that we,
as a society, discuss
and debate this issues.
But we're a civilized society.
That's how we do it.
We don't kill people
and we don't sit there
and somehow explain
people that kill people.
And when he brings
up disenfranchised
and -- what was the other term?
Disenfranchised --
-- minorities, I mean, Signe and I,
we've done so many cartoons
about women's issues.
You talk about a disenfranchised
minority,
women throughout the world.
And, unfortunately, women tend to
get the real short end of the stick
when it comes to religious
organizations.
They do. I mean, I know that's
something that nobody wants
to talk about, but it's true.
So, you know, like I
said, I respect him.
I just don't agree with him.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Ditto.
[ Laughter ]
I, too think he's, you
know, a master of the craft.
But -- and I think
what Ann's getting
at about feeling slightly
differently as a woman --
the first people who get covered up
and who get told that they can't be
at the altar or, you know, that they
can't go to the Wailing Wall, or,
you know, to offer their prayers
in the same place men do, it's --
I mean, this is, this
is religion in action.
And from a woman's point of view
it's always a little difficult
to say, oh, okay, that's fine, and
please go to my state legislature
and pass some laws
based on your religion.
I just feel like -- as Ann
said, if you're going to enter
into the political fray and a lot
of religions do, then you're part
of politics, and you have to
be treated as a politician.
That's what cartoonists do.
So I feel that at the other --
the specific problem or
the specific accusation,
both for the Danish cartoons
and the Charlie Hebdo cartoons
was these people weren't
really journalists.
And the Danish cartoon, the
magazine was some right wing rag.
Well, Flemming Rose,
the Editor of that rag,
was a foreign correspondent based
here in Washington for many years.
And then also in Russia.
He speaks fluent English
and fluent Russian.
I've sat at a table with him
where he's talking about towns,
tiny little towns and their
mayors in the Ukraine.
This is a serious journalist.
He didn't just do --
cook this up on a whim
which is what he was
accused of doing.
So I reject that.
It's an issue that's -- the issue
of immigration is a live issue
in many European countries.
This is how they dealt with it.
And one small sliver dealt
with it and, again, it's --
it should have been the
start of a conversation
between people, not the end of it.
And I would say the same thing for
Charlie Hebdo except, you know,
Charlie Hebdo -- the cartoons,
the circulation was going down.
People weren't reading
Charlie Hebdo .
If they had just left them alone,
there would have been
one reader left.
And that would have
solved the problem
for them before the people
who objected to them.
And then there's always the
ability to draw your own cartoons.
And cartoonists around
the world are doing that,
so grab a pen, not a gun.
What was that?
>> I have a question
on a lighter note.
I was wondering if you all were
both news hounds growing up
and if you weren't doing this, what
do you think you would be doing?
>> Were you a news hound?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Well,
at Girl Scout Camp I did
the underground newspaper
with a friend, but [laughter].
And at the Academy of Natural
Sciences in Philadelphia
where I worked to earn
money to go to art school,
we had the underground
newspaper going there, too.
But, so I've been, you know,
interested in commentary generally.
But I am not -- I would not say
I'm the best informed person
in the entire United
States of America.
And I don't -- you know, if I --
I think one of the reasons I
would never live in Washington is
that that's all people talk about.
It's boring after a while.
That's why I like to do cartoons
on different aspects of life,
not just the day-to-day politics.
So, no, I'm not a -- I'm not
as big a news hound
probably as I should be.
>> Ann Telnaes: No.
I actually -- I didn't get
into editorial cartooning
until I was almost 30 years old.
I started out as an animator.
See, everything you learn
when you're young comes
back later to help you.
Yeah. So, I -- and I actually didn't
even read a newspaper in my 20's.
Isn't that horrible?
I became interested in politics
when I watched the Anita
Hill Hearings on television.
And I was, frankly, appalled at what
I saw with both sides of the aisle,
about the questions they were asking
and things they were
saying to Anita Hill.
And having been a woman that worked,
you know, in private businesses,
and I just thought
you guys are crazy.
Of course there's still
sexual harassment
and of course we still
have to deal with it.
So that's when I decided
to put together a portfolio
and send it out.
And I knew nothing about what I
was doing, which is really good
because ignorance is
bliss [laughter].
So -- and that's how I
got into the business.
>> Signe Wilkinson:
Just one other thing
about women not going
into cartooning.
I actually do think that there
is a difference between --
generally speaking,
it's a huge spectrum,
but women take things more
personally, generally, not,
you know, on average, I'm
not making huge stereotypes.
And there're clearly
exceptions to all rules.
But, you know, Steve and
others in this room are --
have gone to AAEC conventions,
our cartooning convention.
It's oh, yeah, I really -- I got,
I got a lot of reaction
out of that one.
Oh, yeah. They really
went after me on that one.
You know? And that's not generally
the reaction that I hear from women.
It's like, oh, my god [laughter].
They didn't like the color I did on
that woman's dress in my cartoon.
No. I'm not saying that.
I didn't say it [laughter].
Erase the tape [laughter].
But it is -- it's -- I'll quit
before I really bury myself, yeah.
Okay, fine.
But I do think that that's
a little bit of an issue.
>> Ann Telnaes: Are we going on?
Next question [laughter].
>> What about recording [inaudible]?
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah.
>> So one of the things that I
read in Gary Trudeau's thing,
and I read your response
to the blog here,
was to talk a little bit
about responsibility.
And you used that word which
I thought was going to be one
of your words that you brought up.
But my question is, is
there a limit to satire?
Is there -- are there things
that are not satirical and then
for our paper problems
or some other ways of --
how would you guys define that?
>> Ann Telnaes: Limits in satire?
>> Are there?
>> Ann Telnaes: Well,
that's really interesting.
>> Because you were
pretty black and white
like there is like no red lines.
>> Ann Telnaes: Right.
>> There can't be any.
I have to be able to say everything.
>> Ann Telnaes: Well, you know, it's
funny, it's funny you should ask
that because I would
encourage everyone to go
to the C-SPAN archives and
pull up Hustler v Falwell.
It's really interesting
because they actually talk
about are their limits in satire.
And they actually use Gary
Trudeau as an example.
They compare him to
what Falwell does --
I mean to what Larry
Flint does in Hustler .
You know, his cartoons blasting H.W.
Bush about his manhood in a box?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Yeah.
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah.
And compare what Larry
Flint did in that Campari ad
to what Gary Trudeau does in his
cartoons about George W. Bush.
And, actually, it sounded like
the court came to the conclusion
that in America -- now we're
talking about America here --
the First Amendment, your Freedom
of Speech, you cannot limit that.
Libel is something different, okay?
That's something completely
different.
And that's what the court
was trying to decide.
But when it comes to satire,
the word they used
was you -- what is it?
You cause personal
harm or something?
>> Signe Wilkinson:
Distress, emotional distress.
>> Ann Telnaes: Distress,
emotional distress,
which basically means
you're hurting my feelings.
And is there a limit there?
And the court came to the
conclusion that is not a limit.
It cannot be because
then you start --
then it's like where is that line?
Who's deciding that line?
And if you -- and I encourage you.
Go back and read that Campari ad.
It's disgusting.
It is just disgusting.
And the court upheld it.
>> Signe Wilkinson: That would
be the liberal William Rehnquist
Supreme Court.
[ Laughter ]
>> Can I ask a question?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Yeah.
>> So to clarify.
When you say that the
Campari ad was disgusting,
I believe you're saying that's
something you would not have been
involved with.
You would not draw or -- I have
no idea what was in this ad.
But that's something
you wouldn't do.
So, if we're talking about the
limits of satire, you're saying,
and I agree with you there should
be no governmental limits on satire,
but you as the individual
cartoonist draw your own limits
on what you think is satirical
versus what you think is people
are disgusting or something else.
>> Ann Telnaes: Well, we
are professionals, you know.
We do know what we're doing.
I think that's why we always get
so pissed off when government tries
to tell us what to
do with our bodies.
We're, you know, we're adults.
We can decide ourselves.
And it's the same thing with satire.
You know, I -- the
thing that I want --
I do not want the tools
being limited to me
if I decide an image needs to be
used because what I believe is
so strong about the
subject matter that I need
to do something that's
going to get your attention.
It doesn't mean I'm going to use it.
But I'm just saying, is I
don't want to see people limit
that because I think it's
-- I know this is a cliche.
It's a slippery slope if
you start doing that because
if you start telling people I don't
like that, I don't like that --
there's a lot of stuff I
don't like that's going
on in this world, you know?
And if I wanted to
start killing people
over it then you'd have a problem.
But -- that the problem is,
is what people think is
and isn't acceptable.
So, I don't know where
I'm going with that.
But go ahead [laughter].
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Well, one
thing I thought was interesting
in the pieces, in response to
Gary Trudeau, was that a number
of cartoonists actually said
they had personal limits
and they've talked about
what they would not choose
to show in their cartoons.
And, anyway, that's just a point
that I thought [inaudible].
>> Ann Telnaes: But the point is
nobody's telling them what their
limits are.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: No,
what their limits are.
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah.
>> Have either of you drawn cartoons
that you wish you hadn't drawn
[inaudible] and take back?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Oh,
only about 40% of them.
[ Laughter ]
No.
>> I mean at the point where you
maybe thought well maybe I did cross
that line.
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
>> Signe Wilkinson: There
are a couple that people took
as way -- that I didn't mean them.
It wasn't that the point,
my point was so extreme,
but I was -- it was a bad cartoon.
If I didn't get my point across and
somebody felt that it was, you know,
that it was saying something
I didn't mean to be saying,
that's not a good cartoon, and I
wished that I'd done it differently,
especially ones that people --
and one in particular I remember was
really taken wrong by an individual,
and I didn't mean to
harm that person.
I had meant it, actually,
in support.
So that was my --
>> Mistakes were made.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Yes, my -- Yeah.
>> Ann Telnaes: Yeah, it's basically
if your cartoon isn't
the way you expected,
you want it to be, come across.
But it's -- we take that
responsibility on ourselves.
You know what I mean?
We'll question ourself and go,
why didn't I do it a certain way?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Right.
>> Ann Telnaes: Or if you
release it on a certain day.
>> Signe Wilkinson: Oh,
you're being such a woman.
[ Laughter ]
>> I was wondering whether the
reactions to your more controversial
or politically incorrect
cartoons, if the reaction varies
by age or generation at all.
Like, in particular --
>> Signe Wilkinson: Yes.
>> -- do those under
30, do they take it
about the same as everybody else?
Or are they more accepting,
less accepting?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Well, since we
don't have any newspaper readers
under 30 --
>> Right.
>> [Clearing throat],
it's really hard to judge.
But I think, yes, I
think you're right.
And I think if you look at the
styles of younger cartoonists,
they're quite different than
my style and Ann's style.
So the next generation
of cartoonists is going
to express things in
very different ways.
So, yeah, I do think that
there's a difference.
Yeah.
>> Is there any cartoonist in the
United States who is as provocative
as the cartoons [inaudible]?
>> Ann Telnaes: Mr. Fish,
Dwayne Booth, great stuff.
Go look at it [laughter].
>> Signe Wilkinson: I --
>> Another --
>> Signe Wilkinson: One
more and then we wrap it up.
Yeah.
>> When we mention the limit
of satires, what is acceptable,
[inaudible] do you mean
the powerful majority
of the [inaudible] minority?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Could
you repeat that, please?
I'm not sure I --
>> The limit of satire
in [inaudible] --
>> Signe Wilkinson: Uh-huh.
>> -- acceptable to you by
differing in the larger,
powerful majority or
[inaudible] minority?
>> Signe Wilkinson: Well, I
think this actually gets to some
of the point that Gary
Trudeau was making.
He was saying that the cartoon -- as
I understand it, that the cartoons
in Charlie Hebdo punched
down on people who did --
who were not in the majority.
And, therefore, it was a --
it's a cheap shot because they don't
have the same power as the majority,
either the majority
of the cartoonists
or the majority in the country.
But -- and I think that
generally speaking cartoons are,
are seen as more powerful when
they're going after powerful people.
I mean, they're the ones who are
setting the examples in the world.
However, it's hard to say who's on
top and who's on bottom sometimes.
I think in -- when you're
looking at, we'll just say Muslims
at this point in France,
they're a minority.
But in the headlines when
a group that identifies
as a Muslim group takes over
an entire region of a country
and starts executing people
and, you know, asking for --
not asking, demanding forced
conversions, et cetera, et cetera,
it's the same overall
group but I don't feel
like I'm punching down
to criticize them.
So I think it really depends on
what, you know, what the issue is
and where it is you're focusing.
But it gets back to the whole global
that, you know, the global world.
People may feel disenfranchised
one place and quite franchised
in another place, even though the
large umbrella would put them --
they would both be under
the same large umbrella.
So that's, again, one of the
problems in sending cartoons
across cultures and countries.
>> Martha H. Kennedy: Thank you.
I'd like thank both of
our cartoonists again,
and I'd like to thank
all of you for coming.
>> Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.